breaking news here at sky center this
afternoon and this
attributable to the vaccine's minister
nadim zahawi
who has tweeted to say in the past a few
minutes
basically 15 million
amazing team that means that more than
15 million people
in the uk have now had at least one dose
of a
coronavirus vaccine well straight back
to our political correspondent
uh joe pike at westminster and joe that
is highly significant and it's something
that we had been expecting or certainly
the government had wanted to achieve
by mid-february it looks like they've
done it yeah they've been confident
really about achieving this
for many weeks but they have 50 million
people have now received
at least their first dose that covers
all of the top
uh four jcvi groups so those over 70s
those who are
extremely clinically vulnerable let's
read that treat from the museum's
highway 15 million
amazing team we will not rest till we
offer the vaccine to the whole of phase
one that's the one to nine jcbi
categories
of the most vulnerable and all over 50s
by the end of april
and then all adults this is clearly a
very significant
success nick for the government as i say
it means now
the top four groups which is the over
70s extremely clinically vulnerable as
well as
nhs and care workers and care residents
have all been offered their
first job clearly there will be people
who through logistics
have not been able to get their jab
maybe they have turned down
a vaccine so it doesn't necessarily mean
that every single person in all of those
categories
has got a vaccine in their arm but the
government have
met their target a day ahead of the
deadline of course this means according
to some conservative backbenchers this
success means
the government should accelerate their
uh lifting of some lockdown restrictions
with no sign boris
and wants to do that too soon i don't
think we should also expect more
from boris johnson on this uh possibly
something small today a video for
example
but tomorrow we do expect something
bigger perhaps a full-scale number 10
press conference really to highlight
this success
of the uk government and the nhs are
getting to a significant milestone
in our route out of the covert 19
pandemic
all right joe many thanks indeed so
that's our breaking news the vaccines
minister nadeem zahawi they're saying
that 15
million people in the uk have now
received their first
dose of a coronavirus vaccine